GARRETT GROLEMUND: Thank
you everyone for attending.
This will be the first in a
series of three webinars that
focuses on how to use
reproducibility in a business
setting.
And the real gist of
what we're doing here
is over the past few
years, as you may know,
academics have
been very concerned
with the problem
of reproducibility
in data science research.
Here's just one
of many headlines
that the public has read
about reproducibility.
This one comes from Forbes.
But there's been a, quote
unquote, reproducibly crisis
in data science research.
And there's been
a lot of progress
made to address that crisis.
And from a technological
standpoint,
the problem's been
solved in my opinion.
But there are many
cultural changes
that still need to be made.
The cultural changes
don't concern us so much
as the technological solution.
The new technology
that data scientists
are using to make
their work reproducible
has created
unintentional benefits
for people who use data
science in a business setting.
And that's what these
webinars will look at.
The first webinar,
which you're at today,
is Reproducibility
in Production.
And I'm going to talk about
the technological solutions
to the reproducibly
crisis, specifically,
one type of technology
that I'm going
to call Computational
Documents which
are just documents with
executable code inside of them.
I'll show you how you can use
those to create opportunities
both for yourself and the people
who consume your data science
intelligence, whether that's
customers, clients, bosses,
colleagues, so on.
In the second webinar
on September 18,
Thomas Mock will talk about
RStudio Connect in Production.
RStudio Connect is a
production platform
that allows you to share
the types of documents
that we'll be
talking about today.
And it really
completes the circle
in terms of providing
opportunities and advantages
in an everyday
business situation.
In the final webinar,
Kelly O'Briant
will talk about Interactivity
which is probably the largest
opportunity created by the
technology of Computational
Documents.
To go over the best practices
for making interactive material
and tell you the things that
you should be considering
as you develop interactive
material for others to consume,
that webinar will take
place on October 2.
So for today, let's
start by looking at what
Computational Documents are.
This is what I mean by
Computational Document.
Let me exit the
slides for a moment.
Go to RStudio.
This is a
Computational Document.
It's just a regular
document in a file.
You can see text in here.
But it has executable code
embedded throughout the file.
And a Computational
Document is just a document
that contains executable code.
And when you can put executable
code into a document,
then you can allow the reader
of the document to run the code.
And the code can
do things for them.
As someone who knows
how to write code,
you could write
whatever code you
like to do whatever you
want the reader to be
able to do with your document.
This document contains a data
analysis, a very simple one
as a matter of fact.
And the code here just
recreates the analysis.
And this is typical of what
Computational Documents do.
They're a way to solve
reproducibility crisis
by putting the actual
reproducible data
analysis in your report.
So whoever you pass the
report on to has everything
they need to recreate
the data analysis.
For example, I could run the
code that's in this document--
its buttons-- and reproduce
the document as I go.
So here, this analysis
is making some graphs.
We'll look at them
in detail later.
And then the other thing
that this particular type
of document allows you to do
is you can Knit this report.
Both the text that
the author wrote
in the document and the
code that runs the document
is combined.
And so we see the text
here with the code results.
And it creates a
finished presentation
to pass on to someone who
wants to know about our results
but maybe not about the code.
So that's the gist of the
Computational Document.
It is something that can
contain embedded code.
And because it can do
that, it can automatically
reproduce the data
analysis done with code.
And you can see here how
Computational Documents are
a definitive solution to the
reproducibility crisis in data
science.
Everything we need to
reproduce our work is here.
But because we're
reproducing it with code,
not only can we just simply
reproduce the analysis,
we can reproduce the
analysis automatically.
Now, automation is what
creates opportunities
for businesses who want to
use Computational Documents.
And not only does it
create opportunities,
it's going to be a
disruptive technology that
changes how you think about
delivering and performing
data science if you
deliver or perform
or conduct data science
as part of your job.
To put that in perspective, let
me draw a historical analogy.
Go back to the slides.
It's the picture of
the printing press.
The printing press,
famous example
of disruptive technology.
When Johannes Gutenberg
introduce the printing press
into Europe in 1439,
no one can really
foresee the sort of changes that
it would catalyze in society.
Now, the video here is stressing
the reproducible aspect
of the printing press, but
that's actually a red herring.
Monks can reproduce
books by hand
before anyone came along
with a printing press.
What the printing press
did to change society
is it made the reproduction
of books automatable.
It took a little bit
of initial set up.
But after you did that,
you could automatically
reproduce books.
Now compare that to a
Computational Document.
It takes a little
bit of initial set up
to write the document,
to put the code you
want inside the document.
But after you do that set
up, reproducing the analysis
or reproducing the task that
the code does is automatable.
You could pass a
document on to someone
who doesn't know
how to use code,
make it automatically do what
you design the document to do.
What sort of changes
should you expect
this to trigger downstream?
Well again, consider
the printing press.
When it became automatable
to reproduce books,
many things changed.
For the first time
in history, it
was now profitable to
create a book to sell.
And that gave rise to a huge
new industry, the publishing
industry, which is
still with us today.
For the first time
in history, authors
had considerable economic
and political power.
And that triggered new laws.
Copyright laws which
protected authors
from publishers and people
trying to steal their work,
and also censorship laws
which protected the public,
supposedly, from the authors.
Another thing that's very
prominent when we talk printing
press is for the
first time in history,
the Bible was no
longer a black box.
People could look at it without
an intermediary in the form
of a priest or the church.
And they could develop
new interpretations
on what they were working with.
And that led to new conflicts.
And then just more generally,
after it became automatable
to reproduce the sort of
work, it became beneficial--
perhaps for the first time--
for the common person
to learn how to read.
I think some of
these changes are
things that we'll see
on a much smaller scale
as Computational Documents
become more and more used
in our fields.
There's two main
benefits Computational
documents that we're
going to focus on today.
And the first benefit
is for authors.
When you use
Computational Documents
to report your results and
to deliver the insights you
develop with your
data science, you
can start reporting those
results much more efficiently.
You could reuse the same
initial work, the same setup
that you put into making
one document to create
many, many documents.
The second change that
Computational Documents
facilitate is for users.
The people who
consume your reports
that you generate with
Computational Documents
can interact with the
content in new ways.
Ways that might be
very valuable to them.
We thought they might
be very excited to have
and even willing to pay for.
So we're going to
look at how you
can create Computational
Documents that you
can use in either of these
ways to make your life better.
For the remainder
of the webinar,
we'll look at R
Markdown which is
a technology that
makes it easy to create
Computational Documents.
I'll give you some
tips about the features
of R Markdown that, I
think, have the largest
payoff for using
Computational Documents
in this sort of business
or production setting.
And then finally,
we'll think about how
to include interactivity or
not include interactivity
in the documents that you make.
Now, throughout this
webinar and the two webinars
that follow in the
series, we're going
to talk about the
word "production."
And I want to be clear
up front that production
means different things
to different people,
and we're aware of that.
So please don't be distracted
by the word production
if it shows up in
these webinars.
But that we just mean that
these materials that we're
showing you are ready to use
however you want to use them
and with whoever you
want to use them with.
All right.
So we've looked at the promise
of Computational Documents.
Now, let's look at a way for you
to make Computational Documents
with R. There are many
different ways to make
Computational Documents.
We're going to focus on just
one known as R Markdown.
And again I'll leave the slides
and get it to a demo here.
The example document I
showed you earlier right
here is an R Markdown document.
And R Markdown documents
are just plaintext files,
but they contain three
different types of content.
So if we look at this
file here, you'll
see up here as if all
extension dot rmd.
Don't let that fool you.
Everything in this file
is just a character
and a plain character at that.
So this is a plaintext file that
makes it easy to edit, to save.
If you wanted to use version
control on this file, say--
I have this file saved so if I
delete this and save it again.
I can come over here
to my RStudio tracker.
Go to webinar on the way.
Follow this.
Oh, to rmd and I could diff it.
And since it's just
plaintext it's very easy
to read what's changed here.
This is a git diff.
And it's also easy to save on
GitHub and that sort of thing.
I'm not going to save this
change because it's not
a productive one.
But this file and the other
ones I'm showing you today
will be available
at the shortly.
I'll share it again at
the end of the webinar.
That contains the
materials for today.
So we're looking
at R Markdown file,
and we see that it
does have text here.
It also has code
as we saw before.
And it as a header
here which is just
some metadata about this file.
The three types of
content are demarcated
by combinations of characters.
That's what allows us to
remain a plaintext file.
So if you have--
if you want to have
code in your file,
you can surround it
by three backticks.
And any program that's
aware of this file format
will be able to
recognize that there's
executable code between
those backticks.
If you want to
make a header, you
could surround it
by three dashes.
And if you use one
right plaintext well
you could just write plaintext.
Although I have added
some things here
we'll talk about a bit.
Since this is a
plaintext file, you
can open it in any text editor.
But I would recommend
opening it in RStudio editor
because RStudio is
designed in some ways
to be a text editor
for R Markdown files.
The RStudio ID
will automatically
locate your code chunks in here
surrounded by the backticks.
That allow you to play them in
that fashion I showed earlier.
You can use this as
you write your document
to make the document
effectively a notebook,
a notebook interface.
You can write your
code, test it out,
see if it does what you want
to make the results go away
feel like looking at them.
But if you do like
looking at them,
they appear right here
next to your code.
And then finally, the RStudio
ID provides a Knit button
at the top of your
document which
allows you to use this
plaintext document to generate
a new document that
contains the same content.
At the moment, this document
set up to generate an html file.
The html file has
everything that's
in the original document
including the code results.
In this case, I
asked for RStudio
not to include the
code itself because I
thought I'd be distracting.
And you can see this is
an html file like it's
shared on a website or not.
RStudio opens up a preview
so I could see the results
and read them.
And then if I look
down here, I will
see that the actual
file being previewed
exists in my directory.
That's how I could take it
and share it and do something
with it.
Like I said, this document is
set up to return html output.
But I could use the
dropdown menu here,
and I could create the
same content as a PDF file.
None of this really
affects the plaintext file.
It creates a new separate file.
This file is a PDF file.
So if I submitting to a
journal perhaps or going
to print this out, maybe I
would use the PDF versions
than the html version.
And then also I can make
a Microsoft Word version.
These are just some defaults
that come in RStudio
for making these files.
But the idea behind
R Markdown is
you can use your plaintext
file to generate report
in a limitless
number of formats.
Each report will contain
the same content,
but it will be adapted
to a new format.
In this website,
rmarkdown.rstudio.com/formats,
is an enumerated list of the
options you have available
for changing your plaintext R
Markdown files into new types
of files.
Each of these are a
function or an R package
that can handle an R
Markdown file and turn
into something new.
You see you can make books,
websites, blogs, packages,
no shortage of things
with R Markdown files.
I click through the
flexdashboard one.
This is a way to make
interactive book, to make
DI dashboards R Markdown files.
And if we look at
some of the examples,
maybe click through
on one of them.
Here's the dashboard.
It's made with R Markdown.
If we look at the source
code here, you can see--
here's the familiar R Markdown
header separated by dashes.
Here's some code chunks
separated by backticks.
And there's some
formatting here that
tells what you've been come.
So to recap the
strength of R Markdown--
they're just
plaintext files which
makes them very
portable, very usable.
But you can embed code
in them which makes them
a true Computational Document.
When you author an R Markdown
file, you choose RStudio ID
and you have a
notebook interface
if you like that experience
for testing out your code.
And then finally, the whole
idea behind R Markdown
is that even though you're
working in a plaintext file,
you can generate a report
that is not playing at all.
And in fact, the report
could be in a variety
of different formats.
So far in my example, I just use
the Knit button in R Markdown,
but it is worth noting
that you can also join
these things programmatically.
There is a function in R
Markdown package called Render.
And if you send it the--
fall path your file.
So please help me here.
It will render the file
for you programmatically.
So you don't even
need RStudio ID.
You just need an R terminal
to render these files.
If you do it
programmatically, RStudio ID
isn't going to open a
preview or anything for you.
But the file will
be regenerated,
and it will be saved next
alongside your other file.
So now you know the value
proposition of R Markdown.
Let's look at the features
of R Markdown that
will be the most successful
for making Computational
Documents to share with
consumers of a business nature.
I'm not going to show you every
single thing you need to learn
to create R Markdown files
because I already document all
of this in self-paced
tutorial at this website,
rmarkdown.rstudio.com/lesson
1.html.
This tutorial takes
about 45 minutes
to maybe 90 minutes if you
take your time to finish.
And when you finish it, you
will be an expert in R Markdown.
It's very simple technology.
You just have to
learn the rules,
and they're easy to reapply.
It take you about the length
of this webinar to learn this,
but I'm not going to use
the length of the webinar
to teach it.
Instead I want to focus on the
more high-value features here.
I'm also not going to go very
down into the weeds with R
Markdown because all the details
are documented at this website,
bookdown.org/yihui/rmarkdown
which is the bookdown version
of an actual book
available for purchase.
But the book is available in
its entirety for free online
at this website.
And it documents any
questions that you
might have about R Markdown.
Instead, what I'm
going to focus on
are the features that I think
will pay off the most for you
watching today.
So first of all,
first feature, how
do you create R Markdown file?
If you want to create
an R Markdown file,
go to the RStudio ID, click
File, New File, R Markdown.
And when the wizard
pops up, just click OK.
This will open a file that
has a template inside it.
You can read the
template if you want.
It tells you a little
about R Markdown format,
but typically, you would
just delete everything.
And start writing your
file, or you can just
open a plaintext file and start
writing a file, same thing.
So let's start writing a file.
I'm going to try to recreate
the report that I showed you
earlier.
And to make it easier, I'm
just going to copy and paste
some of the text over here.
So I'm start my report.
The graph below displays
the adverse events
reported for a drug.
This report, it's going
to look at prednisone.
So I'm pretty sure I did
not spill right there.
Well, maybe I did.
And the most common side
effect of prednisone,
I happen to know, is that
the drug is not always
effective which, as side effects
go, is not the worst by far.
So this is a report.
This is a very simple report.
I can write report
that goes on for pages.
But right now, this
will be enough for us.
When you write
text in R Markdown,
you can mark up the text.
For example, if I put
asterisks around it,
then RStudio will know that
I don't want those asterisks
being on final report.
But I want the words
between those asterisks--
save this somewhere--
I want those words to be
italicized in final report.
And so here I have "adverse
events" are in italics.
There's about two dozen signals
you could use to mark up
the text in your final report.
I'm not going to cover
it today, but you
can learn it in the tutorial.
That's why "adverse events" and
the asterisks for what it does.
Instead, I want to focus you
on a more interesting way
to change your text in reports.
You could type out your text
by hand which I've done,
or you could use R code
to generate text for you.
So first let's put
some R code in here.
I'm going to just copy over the
set up chunk from the report
I'm trying to create.
Put it at the top
of the document.
What this chunk does is it loads
some packages in the helper
script that it makes
some functions there.
It takes a drug, it
takes an age range,
it queries the FDA'S
open FDA database
to find out what adverse events
or side effects are associated
with that drug, in
this case, prednisone,
for people of this age range.
And then it makes the data
set out of those things.
Right here, the data
says called "events."
If I want to find out what
the most common side effect is
in the events data set--
that's where "drug ineffective"
comes from--
I could look it up
myself and type it out,
or I could ask R
to find it for me.
So I do--
I have a script, 01 scripts.
It's in the webinar files.
Contains all the
code I'm using today.
It says a script.
This might be how you
typically write R code.
There's no reason not to
write your R code inside an R
Markdown document.
I just have it sort of here,
so I can copy and paste
throughout the webinar.
I ran this code earlier,
events dollar sign
terms, so it looks at the term
column of the events data set.
And it finds out which type of
event has the maximum count.
So this returns,
which side effect
is the most common
for this drug?
If I want the results of
this to finish my code,
I could surround
it by backticks.
And then after the first back
to put the letter R and a space.
Now when I knit this report,
the reports go run that code
and inserts the results right
into my line of code here.
So it says "drug
ineffective" because that
was what you get if you run
this code around this coding
console.
Perhaps, you'll see that.
That adds it right
into my report.
As long as my code
returns something
that's like a number or a
piece of a character string
that could be
inserted into a text,
I can use that code to
finish the report for me.
And the reader won't know
which parts of the report
are hard written
in with real text.
In which parts are
moving parts that
can change as the
results of the code
that generates them change.
So that's the first thing.
It sends a Markdown to make
all events a header here.
If I want to put a
code chunk in here,
I could just type
out the backticks.
It's all just character
conventions after all.
But I prefer to use a keyboard
shortcut which in this case
is option shift I. Option
control I inserts it for me.
Or you can go to the
Insert button up here,
and it will insert
a code chink for you
wherever you want to run.
An interesting thing
revealed by the Insert button
is you don't have to
insert only R code chunks.
You can run any type of code you
like in an R Markdown document.
For example, I could
run Python code
in my document with
the Python code chunk.
You do need to tell
R what type of code
appears in the
code chunk, so you
type the name of the
language inside curly braces
after the three backticks.
No, I'm not a Python user, so
I'm going to stick to R code
today.
But if you're interested in
using other types of coding
on R Markdown document,
specifically Python code,
I recommend that you check out
Sean Lopp's recent webinar,
RStudio in Python, a Love Story.
All right.
Let's use this code
to do something.
You know about some
code over here,
and I will use this code to
make a plot or some ggplot
to code that makes a plot.
I'll put it in this code chunk.
And if I knit the document, now
I added a plot to my report.
But the code that makes the
plot also appears in the report.
So this is my second tip.
If your consumer
is not an R user,
I wouldn't show them
the code in your report.
It makes an experience that they
will process psychologically
very different than if you
just make a plaintext report
that they're used to reading.
If you want to hide the
code in your report,
you could do that by adding a
knitr chunk argument up here
after the R in your code chunk.
And the argument I
suggest you consider using
is echo equals false.
This, will cause the
results of the code
to appear in your report, but
it will hide the code itself
from appearing.
So now when I knit this
document, I have my chart,
but I don't have the code
that creates the chart.
And to be honest, normally
if you're making a graph,
people don't care what code
you're using to make the graph.
They just want to
inspect the graph.
And that's what echo
equals false does for you.
All right.
So we're slowly
building up a report.
It's probably a
bit of a whirlwind,
but hopefully you're going to
sense that it doesn't take too
much to write these reports.
They're actually fairly simple.
All right.
Echo equals false isn't the
only knitr option to consider.
But if you want to
write more options,
you can just start
typing in the new R.
You use tab completion for
a list of possible options.
But learning about these
options is a bit tricky.
I confess because
echo and code chunks,
they're not our functions.
So you can't open an R help
page to learn about them.
So what I recommend is that if
you want to learn about chunk
options in R Markdown, go to
this website, yihui.name/knitr.
And it contains basically the
help pages for every chunk
option in R Markdown.
This would be the
place to go to.
It's the first result when you
Google R Markdown code chunks
or knitr code chunks.
Now that we have some code, you
could consider this a complete
document.
If we look at what we have
over here, run again--
document says, the graph
below displays adverse events
reported for prednisone.
The most common of which
is drug ineffective.
And here's the other
ones on the graph.
This might be all your
consumers are interested in.
And you could pass
this off to them.
But maybe the consumer
gets sick and they
go to the doctor who
prescribes a second drug.
And they want to know what
the adverse events are
for that drug.
You could recreate
this analysis,
create a report for them,
and send it off to them.
But when you're
working with code,
usually you don't want
to repeat yourself.
One, because it's more work.
Two, it invites the chance
to make more mistakes.
But three and most
importantly, you're
working with code
is normally not
necessary to repeat yourself.
And now that we've
written this code,
it's not necessary for
us to repeat ourselves.
We can reuse this report
in multiple places
by adding report parameters.
And to do that, first
we'll have to add a header.
A header is a section
of the report that
doesn't appear in the
finished document that
allows you to enter information
like metadata that customizes
how the reports generate.
To make a header, surround
on each side by three dashes.
It should come at the
start of your document,
and it is a header.
Here, you can do things
like set the default
output for the document.
This would be the
output that gets
used if you call the
render function instead
of choosing one up here.
One of the things you can cite
here is a parameters field.
You could learn how to write
yaml and headers in the R
Markdown tutorial.
So I'm not going over it.
But you could see it's key
value pair separated by colons.
I'm going to create a parameter.
Going in at drug.
And I'm going to give it an
initial value of prednisone
or whatever you want to be.
And now that I've created a
parameter in my header here,
the code in my
document can access
the value of the parameters
as if they were a list.
And actually, I
apologize for it.
Params is the field.
Now my code, they can
access the param's list.
Instead of having a hard
code prednisone here,
I could just access
params dollar sign drug.
And this will return the
value, prednisone because I
set that value to drug here.
If I want more, I'll
must be on that list.
I could have-- name
whatever parameters I want
and set them to whatever
I want them to be.
I don't even have
to use them all.
I do have to spell correctly,
so let's fix this one.
Now that I've created some
parameters, if I go to knit,
it's going to knit my report.
It's going to use the default
value of the parameters,
and I won't see any changes
not time about prednisone.
But if I come down the
knit with parameters,
I will have the option
before I knit the report
to change either of
these parameters.
So we've been looking
at prednisone,
but let's look at a
different drug like Tylenol.
Now I knit through report.
Whatever params dollar sign
drug appears in my code,
it will return Tylenol.
If I wrote a report
in the correct way,
this will change the entire
report to speak about Tylenol
instead of prednisone.
And you see here,
I miss some places,
but the graph is
talking about Tylenol.
And the most common effect
of Tylenol is nausea.
It doesn't take much to
parameterize the whole report
to use this new params
dollar sign drug.
For example, down here
where I said prednisone,
well, I could insert
some inline R code.
That inline R code could
just return the results
of params dollar sign drug.
This inline R code is
actually pretty useful
since it's creating
the drug name.
And maybe I would use it
up here to create a title.
And now when I knit
this document--
I have prednisone here.
I knit it with parameters.
Stay with Tylenol.
I get my Tylenol document.
I can now use this document
in the similar context
to describe any drug
in the database.
I've automated that work
by putting parameters
into my R Markdown document.
Next, let's look at another
option created by the fact
that there's executable
code in this document.
There are two types
of code in R that
return interactive components.
One type is called htmlwidgets.
Htmlwidgets are a
collection of R packages
that contain functions.
And the functions
build a JavaScript
powered self-contained widget
normally to make a graph that
has interactive properties.
And then there's
the Shiny package
which provides ways to
toggle in a live R session
and to interact with
the R session that
runs in the background
of your document.
Let's look at each
of these separately
because when you combine them
with R Markdown documents,
you very quickly have a way
to create interactive reports
for your consumers.
Start with htmlwidgets,
the best place
to learn about them
is the website,
htmlwidgets.org, so let's there.
Let's jump right
over to the gallery.
Each of these entries here is
a different type of htmlwidgets
that does a different thing.
These widgets are sort of
pre-programmed to use out
of the box.
They all do their thing.
And if that thing is what you
want, then it's your lucky day.
You could just start
using the widget.
If you want to do something that
an html which it doesn't do,
you won't be able
to use htmlwidgets,
so you'll have to use Shiny.
We'll look at that in a minute.
You can see that most
of these htmlwidgets
are designed to make a drafts.
For example, we can make a map
that we could toggle here, make
key maps and read off values.
But for our reports
since our graph
is just fine the
way it is, I'm going
to use the underrated
DataTables widget.
What this widget does is
allow you to actually explore
the raw data in a table.
And to add it to my
plot, all I have to do
is maybe put some
texts this side up.
So this will be our appendix.
The raw data is available.
And then I'll borrow
some code from over here.
I'll put it in a code chunk.
Again using echo's equals
false through backticks.
That my document-- and now as
long as I pass this document
on in an html-based format--
because this is a
JavaScript table--
users can explore
the actual data
they can sort by the different
variables in the data set.
They could decide how much the
one I look at it once and so
on.
So it adds real
value to this report.
And all I did was call a
function that already exists
in R to insert this interactive
htmlwidget into my document
at a certain place.
Now like I said,
htmlwidgets are really
good for doing what
they're designed to do,
but they're not very flexible
for creating new functionality.
On the opposite end of that
spectrum is the Shiny package.
Shiny is designed to let you
do whatever you want to do
in an interactive fashion.
Go to Shiny website.
Here's a very simple example
of Shiny up down here.
You see, I have a drop
down menu that I could
use to select different things.
The graph output
created with our changes
when I make
different selections.
I can select different
dates, overlay smooth line,
and do this map, the graph.
The idea is the user gets
to control some inputs.
The inputs are used behind
the scenes in R analysis.
And the output of that analysis,
be the graph, the table, text
or what have you, is
displayed to the user.
And that changes as the user
changes various components
here.
That's a very simple
Shiny widget or Shiny app,
but you can see
that you can make
some more interesting and
complicated Shiny apps here.
You normally design an html
page that sort of serves as a UI
to the app.
And then you set
up the R session
in the code that runs
in the background.
Well, you do that with R code.
And since you can insert R code
into an R Markdown document,
you could do that in R
Markdown document as well.
Now I have a document that
does the same thing we've
been looking at, but
it uses Shiny functions
like renderPlot and whatnot.
To make the document we were
just looking at interactive,
this document is
now a Shiny app.
A little bit trouble here.
There you go.
So here's a Shiny app.
It's showing us
Tylenol's results.
We also bring it
down by gender here.
Here's our table at the en.
We could change the age ranges
for Tylenol based on like this.
See that the biggest
side effect for Tylenol
is complete suicide.
Didn't expect that.
For older people is fatigue.
And if we want to look at
another drug, let's say, Advil,
we could type in right here.
And the app almost
immediately changes.
This is actually and
truly a Shiny app
made from an R
Markdown document.
You can see the document here.
If we were to add the
flexdashboard formats
to this app, we'd have
an R Markdown document.
But this really looks
like a Shiny app now.
So this is the dashboard
version of that app
I had made through R Markdown.
All right.
So let's pause.
I mean, there's
quite a bit there.
I'd like to recap
what we looked at.
When you're making Computational
Documents with R Markdown,
the opportunities you
should pay attention to
are actually generating
the text of the document
with code using inline code.
Because if you do
that, it will pay off
when you parameterize
a document.
Next, don't think
of it in terms of R.
Don't think of it as a Python,
SAS, JavaScript, whatever
you like to use.
You can put that into
an R Markdown document.
So more exotic languages
will take some work
on your part on the back end.
The things used for data science
like Python are ready to go.
Hide the code from your
users if they're not
looking for a code experience.
And then add parameters to
reports to make them flexible.
Your entire report becomes
like a function in R
that takes some input
and returns some output.
And all you have to do is change
the input to change output.
If you're generating the
text with inline code,
you're actually able to
change the results that
are reported to the user as the
parameters themselves change.
Consider adding htmlwidgets
for self-contained interactive
pieces.
And then consider going to
adding Shiny components if you
need to do some sort
of custom interactions
based on your
unique R algorithms.
If you look at these
things that we went over,
you'll notice here at the end
of these last three options
are sort of like a
hierarchy of ways
to make your report more
and more interactive.
And you could think of this
hierarchy of interactivity
from static R Markdown
documents I wanted to Shiny apps
on the other end which are
completely interactive tools.
All of these are
available for you to use.
And so now, as
someone sophisticated
who can make
Computational Documents,
you need to start thinking
about your strategy
for supplying needs using
these different levels
of interactivity.
So let's look at that,
thinking about interactivity.
Not only does enter
wrong on this hierarchy
create a more
interactive document,
it also requires more
work on your part.
Interactivity's
complicated to make.
And when it come
to making something
like a Shiny app, those of
you who have made Shiny apps,
you know that there is
a lot going on there.
And that is a very
specialized undertaking
to make a Shiny app.
But you don't have to make
a Shiny up every time you
want interactivity.
For example, if you just want
to generate the same report put
on a new drug or on
a new market segment
or on a new updated
database, you
might be able to do that
with the simple R Markdown
document that's been
parameterize with parameters.
Alternatively, if you want
your user be able to poke
and prod the document, you
might want to create a Shiny app
or you might be fine with
an R Markdown document that
uses htmlwidgets or
even an R Markdown
document with Shiny components.
What I recommend is that you aim
for the level of interactivity
that's as simple as
possible to do the task
that you want because that
leaves less room for things
to go wrong and need to be
debugged on your part, less
room for things that go
wrong and for the user app,
of course, experience
and less time needed
to create these documents.
Here's some simple bright
lines that you could use
to think about this hierarchy.
First of all, if
you ask yourself,
how many times do I need to
change the data in my report
during my presentation or during
the viewer's presentation?
How many times are
they going need
to change the data
for themselves?
If it's less than once,
then you don't need
anything that involves Shiny.
This is a very
important question
to ask yourself
because we tend to see
people learn Shiny and
then use it for everything.
It's very hard to walk
back from Shiny once you've
adopted a Shiny workflow.
And that's OK.
Shiny is excellent.
But it's very easy
to overestimate
what you need to accomplish
the results you want.
And if you're not updating
your data more than once
per session, then you can
just use a simple non-Shiny R
Markdown document.
And you can create a new
document before each session.
And that document will
suffice for that session.
The next thing to ask is, do
you need to create a custom
UI for your app?
If what you want to
report to your user
would do fine in a document
format or a dashboard format,
you could do that within
R Markdown document.
And you don't need to invest in
creating a Shiny or an html UI
to contain your
interactive components.
All right.
That is Computational
Documents in a nutshell.
And hopefully from
there, you can
see how you could use some
of the benefits I mentioned.
I think the case for
generating reports
efficiently with parameterized
R Markdown reports source
speaks for itself.
And then adding
interactive components,
either through parameters
or htmlwidgets or Shiny
components, will be the
way to empower your users
to do different things.
But we've really only covered
half of the user story.
Computational Documents
create the opportunity
to give your users
a document that can
run code and interact for them.
But whether or not
that opportunity
will exist at the
user's fingertips
will depend on how you share
that document with their user.
The platform you use
to share the document
will need to be able
to run and execute
the code in your
Computational Document
if you want the user
to be able to execute
that code by interacting
with the document.
And that's what the next
webinar will focus on.
On September 18, we'll
look at RStudio Connect
which is a production platform
for sharing data science
products.
Among the things that you could
share and RStudio Connect are R
Markdown documents
and Shiny apps.
In short, you can share your R--
your Computational Documents.
Computational Documents create
a lot of new opportunities
for letting people interact
with the things that you make.
And RStudio Connect is
built to take advantage
of each of those opportunities.
To give you a taste of
what's happening, last--
I've taken one of the
documents that I've
made in this webinar material.
Now I've put it on a
demonstration RStudio Connect
server.
So I'm going to a website now.
The website is an
RStudio Connect server.
When I get to the website,
I can see all the content
I've posted on RStudio Connect.
And the thing that I posted on
there for days is called 03 rmd
with parameters.
It's a file that's in--
I have materials for today.
And if I click on it,
I could see the file.
It's the same file
we've been looking at.
And I could send
this to my boss.
I could send this to the
president or to Tariff.
You could click
on the file, he'll
see the same thing that I can.
And if he wants to change this
to look at a different drug,
he doesn't need to interact
with the R code at all.
He can use the tab
in RStudio Connect,
and he can choose his drug here.
Aspirin.
And he could run the report.
The code that I
wrote for this report
is now being executed by RStudio
Connect on a server somewhere.
It doesn't matter that
I have R on computer.
That's just-- because I need it.
But you could go here.
And if you had access
to this document,
you could run this without
downloading R. Here,
you could see some
things about aspirin.
The other thing is
since all the codes
here to regenerate this
report whenever I want,
it'd be very easy
for me to do things
like schedule it to be updated.
Whenever I know that the data
itself is getting updated,
it would be very easy for
me to update this report
and automatically email
it to my collaborators
every Monday or Tuesday.
Then it'd be very easy to
see how people have been
interacting with this report
or how this report has changed
over time, perhaps, by
looking at the version
history or something else here.
We'll learn all about that
in two weeks in RStudio
Connect in Production webinar.
All right.
Now, to wrap up this
webinar, here is the link
rstd.io/repro-in-production.
It has versions of the file
that I was developing today
at different
waypoints so you could
see all of the different
technology I put in there.
And thank you.
Thank you for sticking
out to this webinar.
If there's any questions,
I'll do my best
to try to answer them now.
Have any surveys been done on
what percent of data scientists
use Computational Documents
versus those that don't?
I'm not aware of
that research, Steve.
I think Computational
Documents are sort of
in the early adoption phase.
It does also depend
on how liberally you
want to define
Computational Documents.
But what I have seen anecdotally
is that adoption is spreading.
So the percent of data
scientist using these things
will be increasing.
Will pagedown be covered in
this webinar or any others
in the series?
I know, Ryan, pagedown isn't--
it's very interesting but not
really central to the topic
we're covering today.
So we won't cover pagedown.
However, if you go to
rmarkdown.rstudio.com/formats,
that link in the slides, you
will you'll find a link where
you can learn much
more about pagedown.
It is one of the formats.
How do we handle reproducibility
when packaged versions
changes--
package version changes may
cause results to change?
Can we force a certain
version of each package?
Yes, you can do that
depending on your use case.
If you have a budget, if you
work for a company that's
supporting your work
with R professionally,
then you might look into the
RStudio Package Manager which
is a tool designed
specifically to do this
to help your group keep track
of which versions of packages
are being used for what.
It makes it very
simple to reproducibly
track which packages
should be used when
and then to create
libraries of those packages
to use with certain projects.
You can learn more about RStudio
Package Manager at RStudio.com.
It's part of the new
RStudio team bundle.
If you're working as an
individual, depending
on your work and
how you use it, you
might find RStudio
Package Manager
useful to you as
well-- again, if you're
an academic collab or whatnot.
But if you don't want to
use RStudio Package Manager,
you can check out some of the
open source solutions that sort
of get at this problem like
the R EMV package R E-M-V
and the pre-existing packrat
package, P-A-C-K-R-A-T.
Handling changes in versions
and open source software
is probably the
trickiest problem
related to reproducibility when
you use open source software.
And there are many people
working on this problem.
I recommend RStudio
Package Manager
because I know it's a very
professional solution that
will work.
But obviously, when you talk
about open source software,
we're not always looking
for professional solutions.
Can you please repeat the
difference between R setup
versus R for the code chunks.
Yes.
And let's go to the code
and take a look at that.
If I go back to the one
last developing here,
the first chunk has
the word setup in it ,
and the other chunks don't.
You can give any chunk
you want a label.
So I might call this one graph.
They'll help me remember
that this is the chart that
contains the graph.
And if you're
inside RStudio, down
share you can navigate the
chunks like chunk 1, 2, 3.
If I use the labels,
it's much easier
to figure out which
chunk I'm looking
for because the
labels show up here.
They're kind of used
in other places to.
But R Markdown
itself will use one
of the labels in a special way.
If you name a chunk,
"setup," then whenever
you try to run any code
in this document-- so this
was a brand new document.
I just opened it up.
You can see here
in the setup chunk,
I'm sourcing some
needed functions.
I'm creating the data set that's
needed down here for events.
Here's where events is created.
But you can imagine--
excuse me second.
You could imagine sharing
this file with a colleague
and they just want
to make the graph.
They're excited
So they come down here.
They open the file.
They don't create the data.
They don't run any of
that code up there.
They just try to
create the graph.
Well, if events
doesn't exist, they
would get an error message.
But if you put events
or anything else
in the setup chunk,
then no matter
what chunk gets run
first, R Markdown
will ensure that the setup
chunk is run before that chunk.
So the setup chunk is an ideal
place to load your packages,
to download data if the
report relies on it,
to set up intermedia objects
that the chunks flow rely on.
The setup chunk will
always be run at least one
time before anything else
in the document gets run.
And that's why I use the
setup chunk label here.
How does R Markdown
handle htmlwidgets
when rendering into
a PDF and html?
By Edgar.
That's a great question, Edgar.
Htmlwidgets actually
return JavaScript.
They return a JavaScript widget.
And if you put that into an
html document which is then
presented by a web
browser, they'll
know what to do with
that JavaScript widget.
And it's going to work.
And there are multiple
R Markdown formats
that rely on html.
There is ioslides presentations
or other types of slideshows,
blogdown, bookdown.
And anything that's html based,
htmlwidgets will work in.
But htmlwidgets.
Are not PDF widgets.
PDF files are largely
static, and they
don't recognize htmlwidgets.
So if you were to output
that file to a PDF,
the htmlwidget would not appear.
You would not be able to
have an interactive PDF.
You can think of PDFs
really for printing.
And anything you
print out is not
going to be very interactive
unless Origami's involved,
I guess.
How would you generate both
reports as separate documents
but not edit/run each time.
All right.
So I guess, we have a
parameterized report.
And we're talking
about prednisone,
we're talking about Tylenol.
If I go back to RStudio, this
is the parameterized version
of the report.
It's called 07 temp.
I'm going to open
the console here.
Because if I want to
generate both those reports
and not to have to use the
Knit button or whatever,
I would use the R
Markdown render function.
I would pass it this
07-temp.rmd document.
This will render it.
If I just render
it like this, it's
going to use the default values
for these params, parameters
up here.
Then let me--
But let me consult
the help page,
so I don't give out
any incorrect advice.
I could set the
parameter values that I
want to use in the R
Markdown render call.
Right here with the
params argument.
So this is params or so.
If I go in here, might
double colon in there.
Let me go to any other way.
Set params.
I goes to a list.
And here, I could say, I
want a drug equal to Tylenol.
And if I cared about doctor,
I don't actually use that.
I would set that here, too.
Close.
Doctor.
And then when I
run this document,
it will use those
parameters there.
I can also set out
the output file name.
Set that to output file equals
07 Tylenol or something dot
rmd.
OK, so how that
answer your question?
No, but it set up the solution.
If you can generate this
document programmatically
like this, you can
write a for loop that
calls this a number of times.
And each time it calls it,
it passes in a different set
of parameters.
And it passes a different
fall path to save results at.
And by the time that for
loop finishes running,
you'll have i
different documents.
Each uses different
parameters, and each
is saved in its own place.
And that's how you can
generate 100 reports right away
from a parameterized document.
Next question.
MODERATOR: Hey, Garrett,
we're at a-- we're
coming up on five
minutes remaining.
And it looks like we
have a lot of questions.
So first I'll say we'll
post the questions.
And Garrett, if
you're open to it,
you can answer them
in text format,
and we'll have a thread for
that on community.rstudio.com.
And then I would say for the
remaining couple of minutes,
do you want to pick and choose a
couple more just to go through?
GARRETT GROLEMUND: That
sounds like a great plan.
Let's see.
All right.
Well, OK-- so some
question's close to my heart.
What is the best way
to start learning R
for experienced programmers?
I think the book,
R for Data Science,
would be the place
to start if you
want to use R to analyze data.
But if you want to understand
R as a language using what
you already know about
software languages
as an experienced
programmer, then I'd
recommend starting with
the book, Advanced R,
by Hadley Wickham.
Both R for Data
Science and Advanced R
are available for
free online, or you
could purchase a print copy.
When you have
interactivity, does the data
have to be on the server or
available for general user
to interact with?
That's a good
question because it
gets to an important
nuance between Shiny
and non-Shiny things.
I go back to the slides.
Before we're looking
about the slide here.
Shiny is a way to have
an R session running
in the background that the
user can interact with.
And that allows
all sorts of things
because the user at any
moment can do anything
that R can do as long as
you provide a way for them
to do that.
And Shiny is the only technology
that allows that to happen.
Htmlwidgets do not.
Parameters do not.
Parameters will use R
to create the document,
and then R goes away.
And you could take that
parameterized document
to print it out, to get offline
and do whatever you want.
Htmlwidgets will build
a self-contained widget.
When you build an htmlwidget,
it puts in every possibility
for interaction in that widget.
If you have a map
widget, it puts
in the map of the
whole world which
means you could
take that offline
and poke around in the
widget and move around.
And it's going to work for you.
It's only when you
get to Shiny that you
need to have an R
session running somewhere
in the background.
That R session could
be in a couple places.
It could be on
your own computer.
If you have R installed, if you
open the document in RStudio
and you click Run,
you don't need
to be connected to the internet.
RStudio just going to use
your local R session to power
that Shiny app.
And it will work for you.
The second way you
could do it is you
could put that Shiny app
online either with an RStudio
Connect, on Shiny server
pro, or in shinyapps.io.
These are all servers
that are designed
to run in R session in
the background to power
their Shiny apps.
That means that there's an
important use case that you
need to pay attention to.
If you're using Shiny,
you need to make sure
that your server can run an
R session in the background.
And most web servers aren't
designed to run R sessions.
So use your options generally
to use one of the three
I mentioned or also open
source Shiny server.
So I'll leave that there
because this is bringing us
to the top of the hour.
Thank very much, everyone,
for your questions
and for your attention.